to calculate what direction we're firing
the first thing we need to do in our
update code is figure out whether or not
the user has pressed one of the fire
keys fire zero or fire one once they
have the next step we need to do is
figure out what the player's position is
in screen space our render engine
actually defines a function called get
screen position which will actually
project a world space position into the
canvas screen coordinates what this
means is that will now have the player's
position in the same coordinate space as
our mouse input because the two are now
in the same space we simply need to
subtract the mouse input from the player
position to give us a nun normalized
vector a simple normalize will give us a
unit length vector and we can now use
the directional vector as basis to
launch our projectile towards the other
evil evil robot